With just three words, Chris Hemsworth's Thor
spoke for us all in Avengers: Endgame.
When Captain America picked up Thor's hammer
Mjolnir in the battle scene at the end of
the movie, the God of Thunder looked up and
said what we were all thinking:
"I knew it."
It was one of the most powerful scenes in
the whole film, but the exchange didn't always
play out as fans saw it on screen.
In Slashfilm's extensive oral history of Avengers:
Endgame's final battle, the creative powers
behind the film revealed the truth about Thor's
"I knew it!"
line.
Endgame editor Jeff Ford and co-writer Christopher
Markus explained that it actually took a bunch
of takes with Hemsworth before directors Joe
and Anthony Russo found the line that struck
the right tone.
As it turns out, all of that happened during
reshoots.
Ford told Slashfilm:
"It was during a reshoot that we shot a bunch
of lines from Thor for what he would say,
but the best one was, 'I knew it.
We had [Hemsworth] on that rock and we were
like, 'Say this, and this, now this.'"
Captain America's big moment with Mjolnir
was planned out early in the creative process
for Avengers: Endgame, but Thor's reaction
wasn't.
The filmmakers struggled to get it just right.
Different emotions and different intonations
made for very different meanings, and the
Endgame team put Hemsworth through a pretty
intense day of filming to really nail down
the perfect delivery.
Markus explained to Slashfilm:
"They might have all been 'I knew it,' just
with different spins.
The one that's in the script is happy.
I'm sure there was some jealousy, some resentment,
some shock it's such a happy moment for the
audience that I'm glad we went with the happy
one for Thor, because he's sort of the voice
of the audience going, 'F--- yes!'"
According to Avengers: Endgame co-writer Stephen
McFeely, the Marvel crew knew as early as
the summer of 2015 that they wanted to have
Captain America wield Mjolnir at some point
in the film, but they didn't have the big
moment planned out in advance.
As fans recall, Captain America attempted
to pick up Mjolnir in 2015's Avengers: Age
of Ultron, but only shifted the hammer slightly.
Like Thor's celebratory line in Endgame, Cap's
ties to Mjolnir changed over time.
During an appearance on Josh Horowitz's Happy
Sad Confused podcast, Endgame co-director
Anthony Russo explained that Marvel creatives
always understood that Captain America was
worthy of wielding Mjolnir.
In fact, the character himself realized that
during Avengers: Age of Ultron when he manages
to budge the hammer.
Being the good guy that he is, Cap actually
chose not to pick up Mjolnir, as he didn't
want to hurt Thor's pride.
As Russo tells it:
"(It was) In our heads he was able to wield
it, and he didn't know that until that moment
in Ultron when he tried to pick it up.
But Cap's sense of character and his sense
of humility, sort of out of deference to Thor's
ego, you know Cap in that moment realizing
he can move the hammer decides not to."
Some fans have floated another theory about
Cap and Mjolnir: the hero may have become
worthy of wielding the hammer due to the events
of Captain America: Civil War.
It also seems possible that the loss against
Thanos in Infinity War could have changed
Cap, making him more worthy.
Regardless of when Captain America became
worthy, Avengers: Endgame editor Ford said
the moment when he picks up the hammer had
more impact because it happened late in the
Marvel film franchise:
"I think seeing that realized is one of the
pleasures of a long series like this, where
you've really been with these characters for
a long time, so when that happens, it's not
satisfying unless you buy it, and I buy it."
Just like Thor, the audience was cheering
for Captain America in that moment.
Not only was he saving Thor from Thanos, he
was showing that he's always been a truly
mythic superhero.
Like Ford said:
"Cap is that guy."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.